♪
>> Bret: FINALLY TONIGHT.
IT'S FRIDAY.
THAT MEANS NOTABLE
QUOTABLES.
>> MAY THERE BE PEACE.
MAY GOD BLESS THIS EMBASSY.
>> ALWAYS PROVOKING VIOLENCE
ON THE PART OF THE PROBLEM
AND NOT PART OF THE
SOLUTION.
>> HEAVENLY FATHER.
>> I'M NOT A BIGOT.
I'M NOT AN EXTREMIST.
>> MS-13, THESE ARE ANIMALS.
>> IT SEEMS AT TIMES THAT WE
LIVE IN AN AGE OF GRIM
RELATIVISM.
>> IF WE DO NOT CONFRONT THE
CRISIS OF ETHICS AND
INTEGRITY.
THEN AMERICAN DEMOCRACY AS
WE KNOW IT IS ENTERING ITS
TWILIGHT YEARS.
>> WE HAVE A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP.
HE ASKED ME IF I WOULD LIKE
AT Z TEMPT E.
>> WHAT ABOUT JOBS IN
AMERICA, MR. PRESIDENT?
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THE
REPORT THAT -- FIRED?
>> I THINK WE WILL ACTUALLY
HAVE A GOOD RELATIONSHIP
ASSUMING WE HAVE THE
MEETING.
>> I HAVE A LOT FEWER
REBOUNDS THAN DENNIS RODMAN
BUT I DID GET TO SPEND A
GREAT TEAL TIME WITH
CHAIRMAN KIM.
>> LET THE PEOPLE READ IT
FOR THEMSELVES AND DRAW
THEIR OWN CONCLUSIONS.
>> SOME LEAGUES HURT TO HURT
COLLEAGUES AND USE THE MEDIA
TO SCHIFFY EACH OTHER.
>> WOUNDS TO HEAL.
>> THIS IS WHAT THE HAWAII
NATIONAL GUARD IS WORRIED
ABOUT LAVA COVERING ROADS.
>> NEVER WATCH SPORTS THE
SAME WAY.
>> I'M TAKING THE WARRIORS
PLUS ONE AND A HALF.
>> PRINCE CHARLES WILL WALK
THE AMERICAN BRIDE DOWN THE
AISLE.
OF THE PALACE CONFIRMED THIS
MORNING.
>> I ALWAYS SAY INTRO
INVESTIGATORS WORLD UNITE.
I'M NOT GOING TO MEET HIM.
THAT WOULD MEAN I HAVE TO
LEAVE HOME.
>> MR. SPEAKER, WHAT THE
HELL IS WRONG WITH THIS
PLACE.
>> THAT IS SO OBVIOUS LAUREL
AND NOT YANNY.
>> LAUREL.